welcome back James what's coverage of e3
2015 a day three and I'm really excited
about this next one we've got mark here
from TC games and we've got John from WB
games showing us Lego dimensions guys
thank you so much for joining me my
pleasure what have you put on my lovely
clean table so what's some stuff on it
yeah we put actual Lego minifigs
and these are all part of the gaming
experience that these are all real
genuine Lego pigs that interact with the
game so as John's playing through now
anyone you want can just be popped onto
the toy pad once the cutscenes obviously
finished yes and drop down into the game
Oh so we just put Marty McFly on and we
can just see it oh oh we're between a
rock and a hard place I think like the
thing for me is that I I couldn't really
imagine a world where a big company like
Warner Brothers is able to get all of
this stuff together and make it work for
everyone I'm like Oh as well it's just
sort of like all these amazing brands
coexisting in the same place because
we're so used to everyone having their
own thing now everyone's together yes so
it's kind of a cool thing when you take
these franchises and we put the Lego
sheen on them it's just a bit more fun
and people seem more able to accept that
even though it's as you said absolutely
insane I'm so sorry dal it'll bit in the
lego movie yeah but I now which is
taking it to the next level and she's
throwing things in from all across
popular culture so let's talk a little
bit about so this is the toy pad the toy
badge yes this is a technology it was
designed from the ground up yeah
so I creative director Jon Berlin he
started thinking about this whole idea
about eight years ago Wow and he's
waited for the technology to finally get
to a place worth the vision of all the
designers and him could come together so
this was done for the ground up so you
can have seven characters at once and so
that just means that within the game you
can just swap between any of them any
you want so you can happen any character
any vehicle any gadget all seven of them
in any level at any time this
no rules and no boundaries the carrot
the way we thought about it was if you
have a toy box at home as a kid yeah
you don't keep them all separate you mix
them all up and you play and you end up
with a Barbie with an action man top on
you know it's just how it is so why
should you be able to do that in the
game and that's how we've gone forward
with this so see Gandalf's can have got
Top Billing what is that his position
kind of special competitor everyone else
was just too you know wizard no no so
the the sense a bit on the topic so one
of the cool things we've got here is the
vehicles now when you buy your starter
pack you get a Batmobile which is really
cool richer build it but I should
progress through the game you get to
rebuild it two other times and the
bricks are all in that set so you'll be
shown it's the build instruction to you
to keep building and rebuilding and
trying to get in again and again how do
you how do you mean by building is it
like when you have to win you smash a
puzzle in Lego game and you hold down
the action button it builds or you're
talking about like when it was in Lego
Hobbit and you have to select the right
pieces I'm talking about taking the toy
Oh actually build it yet break it into
little pieces again and rebuilding it
into a brand new toy and putting that
into the game that's amazing I was stuck
in like a virtual space oh yeah yeah but
it's like it is an actual still an
actual toy yes so that's a cool thing
we're trying to blur the lines between
digital and physical so your Batmobile
upgrades the next time to the butt
blaster yes and that is the exact same
bricks in that were in that so there's
no change okay and then it goes again
and you continue to upgrade and find new
ways and new exciting ways to play so
let's talk about that you're showing off
today it is the its Aperture Science
Lego up psycho Aperture Science it's
another one of those things I mean valve
a kind of the Masters of storytelling in
video games everyone knows that and it's
kind of a privilege for them to let us
dive into that willing to do anything so
the first time you see a Lego GLaDOS
come down from the ceiling and start
interacting with people or maybe get
misled by Wheatley yeah it kind of it's
an exciting as a gamer and a fan it just
yeah really it's really cool place to be
I mean
so how you see mention le that the
original voice actors are best which is
again another amazing thing so what was
it like kind of writing for that well
luckily we have got such talented
writers though who really sometimes you
just think yeah you should be writing
scripts for you know the big guys well
we'll keep you here that's five we'll
lock you to the desk and you just keep
going and it's really cool and it's you
see the cutscenes they've done for the
first times but that's really funny you
can watch it again in against wood it's
like a comedy show yeah it's really good
to see all right things like the port
the portal ever you can see here that's
actually in the starter set so although
you can purchase like a Lego shell which
is she has a Lego portal gun yeah you
will need to get her to be able to
experience Lego portal that's like nine
levels and a boss fight nine sections
and a boss fight all based around Paulo
it's a huge experience just in the start
packing
I mean is it is it not kind of difficult
to have to write I mean you're writing
your own game your own story you have to
have that but you also have to make it
authentic to the original I do it helps
that we're all geeks we've all played
portal through more times than we can
count
it's the same with other films I mean
you can't count how many times with
watch some of these movies are you can
skip around the office to the sounds of
The Wizard of Oz every day literally
jaunting down our Lego brick road it's
really cool we kind of throw ourselves
in so far into these universities that
we make it special as become always
watching shall here place portals and
it's just it's adorable Lego port
exactly the idea is if you're a fan of
portal yeah you will love this game if
you're a fan of Lego games you'll love
the game we're trying to provide
something for everybody because you can
see it's like the Lego the puzzles like
it's the typical Lego puzzles but it's
like a completely new twist on it
yeah so talking about some of the other
eye peas and stuff so I mean on the
table here we've got scooby-doo we've
got The Wizard of Oz back to the future
Lord of the Rings Batman
like a movie how did how do you choose
wow that's a good question usually
choosing it's just a case of that's a
cool film yeah let's have a play around
with that one does it work yeah I mean
it's like Ghostbusters you kind of think
would that work is Lego let's find out
yeah it works great there we go and it's
funny it's humorous and we've grown off
watching these films yeah what are the
things we found when we was doing like
Lego Lord of the Rings
it was offering an entry point to kids
into this world be a huge pop-culture
franchise and now we've got okay let's
take that to the next level it's all
these films of Wizard of Oz is a really
old film now and still resonates with
the older generation let's bring the
kids in as well let's bring them and
they're asking questions it's really a
good place to be in it's kind of nice
because also for older players who know
and appreciate the IP it's kind of like
hitting the nostalgia for them but
providing as you said like a really good
entry point exactly younger game yeah so
now when a kid goes into store and says
mom dad can I have the latest Lego game
the moment dad can look at what's on
offer and go oh yeah but you've got to
get the girls boosters why would you
need to get you need to get wizards
that's my favorite movie yes exactly
oh so who are we swapping in now I know
we're putting in wyldstyle from the lego
movie how wonderful
so I mean other not restrictions on so
obviously some characters gonna be able
to do things that others car every
character has their own ability yeah of
course you know that's what we need to
something to make them special but every
character vehicle and gadget will go
anywhere you could drop them in at any
time in any place there's nothing to
stop you there's no rules or barriers it
shouldn't be it's playing with toys and
of course as we don't you can play with
friends like any Lego game before co-op
play it's just fun for all the family
the only thing is I don't envy the
people who are gonna argue about which
characters which so you know she'll may
lose a head a few times but that's cool
because their actual make it minifigs
pop oh wow I'm sorry I'm just sort of
like in a portal nostalgia fest here
because it's like is there any
restriction on what you can do with it
no valve and all our IP holders across
the port they've kind of seen what
worried about they've seen our previous
games and they know we're gonna treat
the brand such authenticity and love
this is like shows what you're going to
do don't have fun with it that's what
it's all about fun at the end of the day
if kids adults and everyone enjoys it
then I think everyone's happy so how do
you how does it be a hardest game kind
of work is it this sort of hub world
kind of thing we used to from Lego
Batman 3 or from Lego Lord of rings for
example we have the map and you can
select the the world how do we get from
say the portal world to another so we
have like an overworld called the planet
for Tom and that's why heroes jump
through for the first time so we have a
new bad guy called la Vortech he's
trying to reshape the university his
image pretty lofty and so as the heroes
are pulled through into that vortex they
find a brand new Lego gateway which will
be displayed on the screen and from
there they can jump off into all these
say any different adventures so they may
jump into a Doctor Who level or they may
jump into a Simpsons level or a
scooby-doo level you just don't know and
again that's all part of the starter
pack so I mean personally which is your
favorite of the other packs I get show
to that cuz I say it too much but it's
Doctor Who I'm pretty sure so it's sort
of a great the British exactly exactly
mur so the first time you see a Lego
Peter Capaldi jump out onto the screen
with his lego sonic screwdriver it juice
like all your Christmases come as one
and then he starts like you arguing with
a Lego Batman what's not to love so we
touched on Lego Batman there is it gonna
be the Lego Batman Batman or is it gonna
be the lego movie Batman
well worlds are colliding so why not
have both but I don't want to spoil too
much yeah you'll have to get the game to
find out if Will Arnett's in it yeah I'm
just gonna cry I love that guy so let's
talk now about the puzzles so we're
trying to get the law the evil Lord
vortex who's trying to shape the world
in His image I mean what a guy how I saw
how our heroes kind of fact they've just
found the common ground and they are all
banding together to stop him so when
when he decided he wanted to shake the
world in his image he started to opening
these rifts all different worlds across
the board and as he opened these rifts
some of the heroes friends were
accidentally pulled into them so he
opened one in Gotham City and poor Robin
was just whisked away Batman went after
him and then they find himself in
Parador with Frodo being lost and then
they find themselves in cloud
cuckoo-land with metal beard going
missing so it's all okay well we need to
get our friends back let's team up here
and see what we can do about it so
what's happening right now
oh that's the consideration wait you're
not gonna incinerate more more a
companion game zoom we make if you love
the games you're gonna find something
the reference is in yeah I mean that's
the thing that I always loved about
about Lego games is that when you guys
selves into an IP you really really
delve into an IP whether it's by having
obscure characters or just references
and I think a lot of its great now that
it's voiced so much and that adds a lot
more scope for jokes as well yeah the
cool thing is I mean you touched on
these like having these characters that
no one's heard of for years and it's
just like a single line you know
Wikipedia entry some ways like yes we
have to have that one in the game just
for the one fanboy in the back of the
booth and that's cool because as I said
we're all geeks and we love this stuff
and yeah putting it all together and
getting to play in these amazing sand
boxes he's just so exciting so if I took
for example if I took my my Gandalf to a
friend's house are there any attributes
that would be on my Gandalf or was it
just taking the character character so
the character will just be the character
so he comes with all his abilities of
standard with the vehicles if you
upgrade your vehicle back and go over to
your friend's house so you could go over
to your friends and show off that you've
got a mighty bat blaster and he's not
and then it's like well I'm gonna tell
you how I did that
you have to find out for yourself yeah
lazy yeah learning for yourself so what
comes in the starter pack so the starter
pack is Batman Gandalf wild style a
Batmobile the gateway toy pod and of
course a standard TT game you know
you're going to play through a story in
the starter pack which is completely
comparable to everything we've done
before
there's no scrimping on content yeah
there's a lot in there by getting the
additional characters and expansion
packs you can keep going and going and
going and it becomes something that's
gonna take a while yes I mean obviously
you're Kenneth the kind of comparisons
are gonna be made it to Disney infinity
and Skylanders with Disney infinity it
was like you have the disks you know
like to add extra things into the game
how are you guys gonna add extra toy
sets and things in was it just can be
downloadable content or is it gonna be
so late later on I'm sure it will come
as a download so we've put on the boxes
Internet required because we do want to
keep this as a long-term proposition we
don't just want you to buy this and then
buy another one next year and then buy
another one danira we want this to be
like a console and your TV this is big
it for the long haul and keep going and
going and going and see what new things
we can do and new surprises so one day
you may turn on your console and
something radically different happen who
knows so I mean I assume you've been
play testing this loads have you given
it what it what are the kids reactions
to it well I don't know if it's just too
much sugar but it seems like they're
pretty hyper you know we have people
kids come into the office playing the
game and usually it's just like is that
scooby-doo I know yeah and then they
just run around breaking things up it's
really weird cuz kids play games
completely different to adults yeah so
if we show an adult The Wizard of Oz
they just walk straight down the yellow
brick road say oh this is really cool
we're kids they just like yeah I'm gonna
jump in Benny spaceship and fly all over
the place and shoot all the flying
monkeys and he's great because the game
caters for any way you want to play it
yeah I mean that's I mean that's the way
I kind of play Lego games oh we got
scooby-doo in here now
is that I oh sorry just the animation it
just reminds me of the cartoon yeah it's
sort of an amazing way of encapsulating
and finding the core of the character
and just displaying it on screen because
the way I usually play is that I will
just destroy everything so I feel I kind
of play more like a kid then like an
adult who will just go for the gold yeah
how do you prefer to play I'm the same I
just like to break every little thing in
the label see I like to try and get my
grit multipliers before I get to the end
so like you can get all the cool stuff a
lot quicker but you know we cater for
everyone and it's cool that everyone
plays in a different way
another thing that Lego games are well
known for is collectible oh yeah
how many minifigs what are we what are
we collecting the summer and oh you're
collecting mini kids you're collecting
stewards upgrades the vehicles gold
bricks I mean yeah that the count is
endless trust me you're going to be
constantly finding new things for years
to come
so in the original like a marvel we were
hunting for like Stanley are there gonna
be missing famous faces that we should
be looking out for me maybe oh maybe
there'll be some which reference the the
different brands we have in there
I don't know you'll have to play the
game to find out when can we get our
hands on it and for which platforms it's
the end of September this year and it'll
be major platforms ps3 ps4 xbox one 360
and Wii U wonderful thank you guys so
much for joining me that's like a
dimensions out later this year make sure
you don't get when you have more awesome
games coming right up